if you thought the real housewives of
beverly hills was crazy wait till you
see the real lawyers of the real
housewives of beverly hills
as you may know erica girardi one of the
stars of the real housewives of beverly
hills was married to
a once legendary trial attorney named
tom girardi
tom gerardi created the well-known
plaintiff's term gerardi keys but that
firm is in bankruptcy in part because of
all the allegations of impropriety by
tom girardi among those include a
potentially 20 million dollars that
girardi gave to his then wife erica
erica girardi filed for divorce in
november
of last year erica gerardi's attorney
has tried to withdraw from representing
her
but now has backed away and is now
representing her again
and the federal judge froze all tom
girardi's assets
because was evidence that he stole two
million dollars from spouses and orphans
of a plane crash that he was
representing
yes truth is sometimes crazier than
fiction but one thing is for sure
we will see all of them in court